in 45 anni che insegno in questa scuola
non mi era mai e dico mai capitata una
classe indisciplinata come la vostra!
Ve lo devo proprio eh dire siete la classe
peggiore dell'intero istituto
complimenti!
senti ma ti sembra questo il
modo de sederti? eh che sei in spiaggia?
I' m so sorry, non si va in bagno alla prima ora
ragazzi le vogliamo aprire queste
finestre eh?
dobbiamo cambiare l'aria non si respira
qui dentro!
eh.. guardate che ai miei tempi eh si dava
anche lo zero come voto!
eh Quaranta, non c'é bisogno d'appoggiarsi alla parete eh
guarda che quella sta in piedi da sola, non cade
non si va in bagno prima della
ricreazione
ascolta chiudimi le finestre perché si gela qui dentro eh
siete ancora peggio dei ragazzi di prima!
i bambini dell'asilo si comportano
meglio di voi
ve voglio ricordá che io il
telefono lo uso solo per questioni
scolastiche...
scusate, Cesare senti dammi ancora
un'oretta che finisco
qua la lezione e poi arrivo a casa va bene?
é appena finita la ricreazione e tu non sei
andato in bagno, sono cavoli tuoi!
si ma senti queste qua cosa sono?? eh?
mele? pere? carote?
vogliamo metterla l'unità di
misura ogni tanto?
pensate che mi piaccia darvi tutti
questi compiti a casa?eh?
sì mi piace e allora???
la vostra é una generazione che non ha
più valori ragazzi eh
siete sempre attaccati a sti
telefonini
lunedì alla prima ora verifica su tutto il programma eh
buon weekend a tutti
ti vuoi togliere quel cappellino?? eh
non siamo mica un concerto rock
ragazzi so sincera : i ragazzi delle altre classi
sono molto più avanti di voi col
programma
é l'ultima ora te la tieni e
la fai a casa tua!
c'é qualche volontario?
no? allora chiamo io!
io vi avviso il prossimo che mi chiede
se ho corretto i compiti viene sospeso immediatamente!
se ci fosse un esame per
diventare asini lo passereste tutti!!!
ragazzi se non avete capito ditemelo eh
che ve lo rispiego
Prof io non ho capito!
perché non stai attento, devi stare più
attento!
non è che posso sempre rispiegá le stesse cose,
mó t'arrangi eh
Prof posso andare in bagno?
chiedimelo in Inglese
Eh...can I go to the toilet please?
NO.
YOU CAN'T!
Qualcuno ha voglia di andarmi a fare due fotocopie?
tu che non hai alzato la mano, vai!
ragazzi so che é l'ultima ora e siete stanchi ma
sono stanca anche io eh
allora io che ho 55 anni, due figlie, separat, con l'ernia al
disco, 200 studenti, 60 classi eh non vado
in bagno dalle 7 del mattino e voi siete
già incontinenti così giovani?
allora ragazzi è molto importante : tutto
quello che sto per scrivere, ricopiatelo
perché poi ve lo trovate nel compito
va bene?
eh, poi non dite che non v'avevo
avvisato
bene spero che abbiate copiato tutti!
guardate che lo Stato mi paga lo stesso eh
se io vi faccio o non vi faccio lezione
é uguale eh
io guadagno comunque, siete voi che non imparate niente!
ma è possibile che non riesco neanche a
sentí sto ragazzo che sta a un metro di
distanza da me
per colpa de tutto il casino che fate?
laggiù in fondo la
smettete di fare salotto?
non siamo mica al mercato qui eh
allora ragazzi mi sembra d'aver capito che non vi è chiaro eh
allora vi faccio un altro schema così magari capite
va bene?
attenzione eh
questo magari era un pó
complicato
adesso ve ne faccio uno più semplice
allora
più chiaro vero?
io amo il mio lavoro ma voi mi fate
proprio passare la voglia!
eh mi son dimenticata di dirvi una cosa e poi non
dite che non vi avevo avvisato!
se questo video arriverà a 90 MILA like
girerò un altro video si
professori e mi raccomando se non
l'avete ancora fatto ISCRIVETEVI a
questo canale eh
non ve lo dico più e soprattutto seguitemi
sugli altri social
su INSTAGRAM
che metto le mie foto in bikini eh
e anche su TIKTOK
che faccio i balletti lo sapete già
anche su Facebook va bene basta mi sono
stufata me ne vado ciao